i'm gonna give you a story here we're
gonna talk about critical race theory i
know you guys
know all about critical race theory we
have talked about it quite
endlessly this is a horrific set of
ideas that
implies that the united states founding
principles were racism that things like
being on time
and working hard and doing your job that
these are somehow white characteristics
which if they are white characteristics
then it seems like white supremacists
would be
a pretty great bunch of people who would
be pretty productive that you'd want to
be around
i mean the whole thing is just backwards
nonsense you all know that but in
some places in the united states they're
actually officially putting it into
schools
and in other places in the united states
they're actually getting rid of it so
we've got some quotes here
from the federalists and this starts us
with washington state
as several states move to ban toxic
critical race theory from indoctrinating
students the state of washington
is leaning in the race obsessed
framework isn't relegated to schools in
seattle where you'd expect
a victim-centered ideology like critical
race theory to flourish
thanks to the state's
democrat-controlled legislature
a trio of bills just signed into law
mandates critical race theory
training for all public school teachers
another even requires training for
medical students teaching them that it's
essential to be social justice
activists as it is to treat patients
staffers learn that black people cannot
be racist because they don't
have power that whites benefit from
white privilege even if they experience
high poverty
and that virtually every american
institution is founded
in white supremacy okay so
washington you're not a good place i say
that with all due irony
i'm here in california not a good place
either but understand that
systemic racism the stuff that joe biden
was talking about
in story number one that doesn't really
exist they are the ones
putting it into the system they are
going to train
a generation of young people through
training a generation of teachers
that somehow black people can't be
racist i mean jemele hill
is a racist all of the people pushing
critical
race theory are racist right we we
know this if i you can be a racist i
don't care what your skin color is i
don't care for these semantic games
that they want to play if you're a black
person and you want white people to be
treated differently under the law
and you don't like white people just
because the color of their skin you're a
racist and saying goes if you're a white
person and you don't want black people
or whatever it is you're a racist too
like stop playing these we're all
playing these ridiculous semantic games
with these people who would never afford
us the the opportunity to
be wide in our thoughts but we're
supposed to always give them
the absolute benefit of the doubt then i
saw this morning
that randy weingarten who's the head of
the teachers union and this woman is
just completely
bananas if you don't think she's bananas
go look at her twitter flag her avatar
is the flag it's the trans flag with the
black and brown flag on top of it
and another flag on top of it and a flag
on top of that the woman believes in
everything and when you believe in
everything you actually believe in
nothing
can you guys tell them caffeinated this
morning um
well i saw a tweet from her where she
tweets out an article by the aclu
claiming that right wingers are trying
to
stop uh people from learning about
racism in schools and it's
just a complete lie it's not that
right-wingers are stopping anyone from
teaching racism at school
if you go to any public school you learn
about slavery you learn about the
history of america you learn all of
those things
i've never heard a conservative person
or a crazy right-winger
say we can't talk about racism or we
can't talk about slavery or we can't
have an honest assessment
of the history of the united states what
they're trying to ban is critical race
theory which is race
essentialism in schools which is telling
white people that they are
less while telling black people that
they are more
this is the reverse of that martin
luther king thing i know you know it
already
but these people they're all liars and
buffoons and i don't know what we're
supposed to do with them
anyway there are some decent people
around uh ron desantis who of course is
the governor
of the great state of florida can we
reach out to him when i'm there next
week let's see if we can pull something
off all right we all we already have all
right
let's see if i can get a meeting with uh
with governor desantis
he is banning critical race theory in
florida but don't take my word for it
let's listen to him
this proposition that we are a
systemically racist country
your reaction well it's a bunch of horse
manure i mean
give me a break this country uh has had
more opportunity for more people
than any country in the history of the
world and it doesn't matter where you
trace your ancestry from
we've had people that have been able to
succeed and all and here's the problem
with things like critical race theory
that they're peddling
they're basically saying all our
institutions are are bankrupt
and they're they're illegitimate okay so
how do you have a society
if everything in your society is
illegitimate so it's a very harmful
ideology
and i would say uh really a a race-based
version
of a marxist type ideology so we've
banned it in our schools here in florida
we're not going to put any taxpayer
dollars to critical race theory
and we want to treat people as
individuals not as members of groups
god that is what a decent public servant
looks and sounds like that is someone
who does not want a generation
of people to be brainwashed that is
someone who wants people to be free
and talks about the individual which is
the most fundamental building block that
we've got here
in the united states i mean that is just
please become
president ron desantis oh please let it
happen let it happen
uh but if you don't think that's enough
uh oh oh i want to
actually address one other thing he says
when he's talking about the institutions
if
your point is and this is their point
that all of the institutions are
fundamentally evil and
and whatever and i by the way i sort of
agree at this point
the institutions are evil but not
because of them being racist it's
because these people have overtaken the
institutions right
their argument is that all of the
institutions our political institutions
our cultural institutions all of our
um all of our businesses our
corporations their argument is that
they're all racist
thus evil no they weren't and they
haven't been
they now as these people have infected
the host right the alien
uh analogy that i always give they've
taken over the body
they're the ones that have made these
things racist
okay that is the problem